So, when you're talking to your students about Jesus,
do you automatically assume that they
believe Jesus to be God?
For years I did.
I just assumed it until I got into a conversation with them about it,
and I realized that that's
not always the case.
Not that long ago,
I was actually talking with a couple of young guys that came to my
door.
They were Mormons.
Super nice, very friendly, had a great conversation with them,
and naturally I went right to talking
about Jesus, because at first we agreed on a ton of things,
which I expected to be the
case.
But then, once we started talking about Jesus, although it seemed like we were going
to agree,
it was very quickly realized that where I thought we would disagree is exactly
where I thought we would disagree.
And I went right to John 8.
And what I love about this passage is that Jesus just sort of flat out says it.
He just says who he is, which is partially why, or almost entirely why they want the
Pharisees and their religious leaders want to kill him, because Jesus says, before
Abraham was born, I am.
And I asked these guys, what do you think Jesus means here?
What do you think this is?
And they said, well, they stumbled from it,
and they really couldn't come up with a good
answer,
and they flipped to another passage and started talking about something different.
And I tried to redirect them back, and it reminded me of a lot of the conversations
that I've had with students over the years.
And I'm making that mistake of just assuming that when we talk about Jesus,
we're talking
about the same thing.
So it's very possible that even in your context, when you talk about Jesus,
you may be talking in a different plane than some of your students are.
But this is a great opportunity to be crystal clear on exactly who it is that Jesus
actually
is, and who does he say he is, right?
And that's why we have students focus right in on John 8,
because it's here that Jesus
makes the flat out statement, before Abraham was born, I am.
The focus here is who Jesus claims to be.
So we ask students in the intro activity to put down who they think they are, what
their family and friends would say about them, and then does that match up.
And do they have evidence for this?
Like, they think they're somebody, they think they're a soccer player, or a
Christian, or a musician, or a football player, or whatever.
Do they have evidence for it?
I used to call myself a football player because I played football, but a person
once brought it up to me and said, you don't really play football.
I said, well, what do you mean?
So we used to hit the bench.
So was I really a football player?
Probably not so much, right?
So who do they think they are and what evidence for it?
So the trick of it is, is that if Jesus says who he is, but we have
evidence for who he says he is, now we've got something, right?
If someone says they're a basketball player and they scored 35 points
the night before, they're clearly a basketball player.
There's evidence for it.
So this is the time you can actually have your students do some of this
interaction nicely and gently and with respect, of course, with each other
in your large group time to kind of get this idea of, do I have evidence
for who I think I am?
And do I have evidence for who somebody else thinks that they are?
So it'd be a good opportunity to do some of that interaction.
So in your small group time, one thing that I bet is probably going to
come out and you'll want to make sure your small group leaders are ready
to deal with it is it's not hard, I don't think, to look at Jesus
as a great moral teacher, as someone who has this wonderful,
you know, religious sage kind of vibe going on where they, you know,
they can read what he says about love and forgiveness and acceptance
and mercy and justice and all these great things that Jesus talks
about like in the Sermon on the Mount kind of stuff and leave it there.
And then go on and say, I'm going to try to follow what Jesus says
as a good moral teacher, but I'm not ready to accept him as the God
of the universe, the creator of all, because if I accept him as the God
of the universe and the creator of all, that has wider implications
for me that I'm ready to accept.
See, it's easy to accept him as a good moral teacher because I can
choose to ignore his teachings if I so choose to.
I can do whatever I want when I want.
And when I choose to follow his teachings, I look awesome.
If I don't, no one's really going to notice, right?
But if I'm held accountable to the God of the universe,
that's a whole other story.
So believe it or not, one thing that I found amongst some of my students
when I was back when I was teaching was that a lot of students
really loved Jesus and really liked what he taught,
but had very little to no intention of ever following him as God.
And that bothered me.
And it was right there.
It was under my nose.
And half the time, I don't even know if I even noticed it.
But after a while, it became very apparent when
I started looking for it.
So it changed the way I taught and it changed the way
I started to converse with some of my students.
And he started to challenge them.
And I think a small group in this time, in this lesson,
might be a perfect opportunity for you
to challenge your students in this question of how
do you see Jesus?
Similar to how Jesus addressed Peter in Matthew chapter 16.
Who do you say I am?
Ask your students, who do you say Jesus is?
And when they answer you, whatever their answer is,
ask them why.
Get some answers out of them as to why they think that.
And if they're in that place where Jesus is just
a good moral teacher, ask them what it would take to get them
to see him as God.
Is there enough evidence?
I mean, you've presented the evidence.
There's a whole bunch of it.
If you look through all the verses,
we've only given you a spattering of the verses
that show that Jesus is God.
So what does that mean for them?
Is there not enough evidence or they're just not willing?
It can be an eye-opening experience.
I'll be honest.
I'm not telling you there's anything you can actually do
about it physically right at this moment.
But it definitely will change the way you approach those
students, the way you address them,
the way you teach them, the way you pray for them.
So I would encourage you to dive into that.
It's sort of a scary place to dive into a little bit,
but I would encourage you to do that.